hello everyone a lot of gentlemen play
chess but there are very few chess
players who are true gentlemen such as
the person you will see in you in the
next photo challenge and now a lot of
you should know who he is although the
photo is from you know an awkward angle
so this might make it a bit difficult
for you but I will give you a couple of
hints so this is the photo who is the
gentleman holding the simultaneous
exhibition on the right it's it's a
photo taken from 1979 in Banja Luka and
another hint that you might find
interesting is that this person in 1916
Martin Mar del Plata when he first faced
Bobby Fischer at the feeded Bobby
Fischer with the white pieces playing
the Kings gambit so there we have it if
you find out who this person is you can
even check out this game I made a video
on it some one year a year ago I guess I
will not put a link in the description
below you have to find it for yourselves
that is also the challenge so getting
back to the game it's a it's a game from
round seven also from day one of the
Grantchester is your next move
tournament it's a blitz game between we
found an island and Alexander Greece
shook so it's quite an interesting game
and a lot of a lot of you know
interesting events occurred in this game
so let's check it out
and before we check out the game we do
have this amazing photo of Alexander
Greece we was taken today by David wada
and I don't know let's let's just enjoy
it for for a couple of seconds so there
it is he's ready for his game if you if
you if you enjoy it just photography you
know and I'm sure you do as a lot of you
are very excited for the photo
challenges make sure to follow that with
lot I will put all of the links to the
social media in the description below
he's very active on all of his social
media so I'm sure you guys will enjoy it
let's check out this game so we have
efore c5 Knight to f3 d6 and beef Bishop
to b5 let me just
so we have the Sicilian defense and the
canal attack it's different than the
Rosalie management II know variation as
this point is on D 7 D 6 instead of on D
seven in the night is not developed
already on c6 and here Knight to c6
Knight to d7 is all all well but Bishop
to d7 was playing in this game it's a
difference depending on do you wanna
keep on the pressure or do you wanna
exchange your bishops immediately so
Bishop captures Queen captures and we
have castles Knight to f6 Queen to e2
defending the e4 pawn knight c6 and V 3
now g6 Bishop to b2 basically g7 and c4
locking down the position and really
creating a very nice outpost on d5 for
Islands night but also it creates a
weakness on d4 so Greece will be able to
use the d4 square for his own night nice
to h5 immediately forcing the trade of
dark square bishop who have characters
captures and Knight to c3 and now all of
all four bishops are all over the board
and now it's a it's a nice game we have
castles Queen to e3 and now II five and
here d3 Queen to h6 seems very dangerous
you know Knight g5 it's gonna be very
hard to prevent checkmate on h7 but f6
and you simply keep this night away from
g5 this night is coming to e6 10 to d4
always well for black here so after 95
after e5 d 3 we have f5 nice the b5 f 4
now kicking the Queen back we have Queen
to d2 and now Knight to e6 are preparing
to bring either of the night study 4
depending on what white place we have B
for g5 now B captors on c5 and now D
captures on C 5 H 3 and H 5 here
preparing g4 at some point we have nice
to H to Bush Queen to g7 and now f3
stopping g4 and hero rook to f7 in
advance defending the b7 pawn because
white will play rugby 1 at some point
also may be preparing to
upon the F file and okay it's a blitz
game so you might get the urge to try
and bust open the position immediately
and while it seems interesting it
doesn't really work after F characters H
captures white simply captures and black
is down upon and f3 doesn't give you all
that much because white has Queen to e1
and after you capture simply Knight to
f6 check and now if you go King to h8
you're getting checkmated Queen has to
block this would be checkmate and F if
you try to run away King a7 then rope to
a 5 you simply ignored the jeep own and
white attack will be unstoppable now the
King has nowhere to go and this Knight
has so many nice discoveries it's gonna
be very painful
so after f3 rope to f7 we have looked to
be one the beep one is already defended
night e to D for so a very nice knight
on d5 but also a very nice knight on d4
rope to be two we have looked to the
eight and now rook a2 b1 pressuring the
b7 pawn b6 and Queen to d1 so if you
look at the position now as long as the
white prevents the black from pushing g4
there's a there's really little black
can do to push forward white can maybe
eventually break through by a4 a5 but
that's only if this night ever moves
from c6 so now we have its only move 24
but now the players are really gonna go
back and forth back and forth and it's
really nothing will be happening for
quite some time so we have Ruby 6 a3
King h7 rogue does come to a 2 may be
preparing to pull the a pawn rook g6 we
have rook back to be to go into f8 rook
to a2 Queen d6 route 8 B 2 you know you
want to play a move without ruining your
position but without spending too much
time as it is a blitz game so rook F to
g7 a for now if this night ever moves
then a5 will be a possibility Queen to
d8 now look back to a-1 rook to h6 rook
8 B 1 knife to a5 now stopping a5 from
ever happening
Queen to e1 we have Queen back to d7
Queen to d1 and here
ratio gets a very nice idea he plays
King to h8 but he's still probably
considering it rook to f2 we have night
8 SC 6 route back to be 2 and 2 Queen to
e6 rook to be one King to h7 rugby to be
to Luke H to g6 rook be one Queen back
to d6 Ruby to be two Queen to d8 Rock to
be one Queen to f8 route B to B 2 and
Queen to d6 so it's very hard to achieve
anything we just don't want to waste too
much time
a ruby one Queen D être bébé to rook to
b7 rook to be one and now a five we have
a rook F to be to night before rook to
f2 and now rugby back to g7 rugby to be
to Queen d6r up to be one and now King
g8 here
Grichuk is not satisfied with the draw
everything is perfectly in the position
all of his pawns are you know ideally
placed well not maybe not ideally but
ideally as possible here's his knights
are placed very nicely and now he gets a
plane he will transfer his King all the
way to the Queen side and then he will
bust open the King side so Ruby b2 we
have King to a fate and now rugby one
Anand is simply waiting to see what
degree she will do a king yet Brooksie
one King d8 room be one King c8 Ruby b2
King b7 rugby one and now King to a7
rook bb2 and now Queen to e6 and here we
have rope to be one and it seems like
all of the moves are the same but the
rook to be one was actually a tiny
inaccuracy by Greek as this rook would
have been much better here on second
rank defending the Jie du Pont so we
have worked to be one and now busting
open with g4 we have F captures and g4 h
captures Knight captures on g4 and now
we should sacrifice the exchange rook
captures on g4 h captures on g4 and here
rook captures energy for route captors
and g4 again and and in accuracy as
there was a much better move instead of
automatically recapturing first Queen to
h6 should have been played now rook to
h7 is a terrible threat because it will
allow Queen to h1 checkmate and after
you
try and stop this for example rook f1 to
create a flight square for your king it
doesn't work still rook to h7 and if you
try to escape Queen h4 there is no wear
your pink can go to because now the
queen is covering a1 and the pawn and
Knight are creating a wall so the King
has to go back
King G 1 now when h2 checking of two now
Queen g3 check you want your king and g1
but only while the queen is on g3 and
now a rook to h2 you threaten checkmate
once again and after you prevent this
rook f2 now Queen to h4 and now you get
the same idea now rook to H 1 will be
checkmate and there is nothing you can
do here you can't escape the knight is
covering e2 whatever you play simply
black the white is getting checkmated so
here after H captors in G for the
automatic rook captures in g4 not the
most precise idea but it's about the
game you know who's to say moves will be
precise rook captures and g4 we have
night to c7 attacking the Queen Queen to
g6 and now Knights the b5 check Knight
captures pawn captures and rook to g3
rugby to be to bringing the rook back to
the defense of the g2 pawn Knight
capture son d3 and now rook b2b Ruby to
d2 of course you cannot capture the rock
if you capture the road and rook d7 wins
the game for white king b8 rook to the
8th check King b7 and you're just
getting checkmated here
so after this Queen captures on e4 was
played here we have rook to f3 see for
defending the knight rook captures and
g3 pawn captures and g3 and Queen to e2
offering a trade of Queens we have Queen
to d4 check King to f1 and here we have
another very nice critical moment in the
game where Alexander we should once
again missus to take home the whole
point
he misses Queen h4 with the threat of
Queen to h1 checkmate and after this is
prevented with Queen to d1 we simply
check the king king moves now Queen to
h5 check King moves now Queen to g5
check King moves and now Queen to f5
threatening checkmate here and after
this is prevented
to f1 now Knight to f4 check King to d1
loses immediately the Queen to be one
checkmated the knight is covering the e2
square and if you try to go up with the
king it doesn't help you have 95 check
you have to protect the Queen King e2
now Knight to c3 check once again you
have to protect the Queen after King e1
now we get Queen to be 1 check we have
to block as the knight is once again
covering e 2 and the point is covering
after so the King has nowhere to go you
have to block and Queen the one will be
checkmate he instead after this King to
f1 move plays Queen to f4 and it seems
like the idea is the same because now
the Queen is attacking the rook if if
the Queen blocks then black wins the
rook
but the problem is Anand plays Queen to
f3 and he is very happy about it because
now if you capture the rook then then
you will get a perpetual check and of
course you cannot straight Queens if you
trade Queens then it's actually white
that can play this game for win yes he
is down to pawns but it's still a rock
against the knife this point will be
will be eliminated very shortly and you
know anything can happen here so after
this Queen to f3 agree she didn't find
anything anything interesting to play he
decided ok yeah I messed up we're gonna
draw this game and he played queen
capture sandy 2 and this is the magic
moment where it where it happened here
of course you see that Queen f7 check
and wherever the black King goes the
white pink and simply keep on checking
him simply check check check check check
check check and you know it's gonna be a
perpetual check and the game will be and
it will end in a draw the problem is
after Queen capture sandy - bye bye
Greece shook on and did grab his Queen
and he was going all the way here but he
didn't play Queen to f7 check instead I
don't played Queen to f8 and he offered
a draw and it was in this position the
head angry she accepted a draw
he didn't accept it but it was even
before on the placed his Queen and
Grichuk was expecting Queen to f7 check
and before and even made the move or it
was right about at the time I made a
move
Grisha already grabbed his
so he had to play with the king the only
play only move you can make with the
king is King to be seven and after that
White will be able to continue with the
perpetual checking about the problem is
after this move on and played and
greased Chuck has Queen to e1 checkmate
or not even Queen to he want he can also
play Queen to d1 checkmate so whichever
you prefer
so two different checkmates in one
available so but unfortunately he
expected Queen to f7 and when Anand
played the Queen to f8 he already
grabbed the King and he saw that he has
to play King to b7 and it was in this
position that he agreed to a draw even
though he has checkmate in one so na you
know I mean I've seen players in this
checkmate in one in a lot of a lot of
times we even had that game again event
took against Anand we also had that car
pool versus beret of a lot of chronic
missed check and mate in one against the
deep Fritz so a lot of different
different interesting meeting one misses
throughout chest history but I believe
this is the first time I saw something
like this that like it's like a mouse
slip it's like a mouse slip and then
it's like Grisha have removed King b7 in
real life so very interesting and yeah I
almost forgot
we even have sorry we even have a photo
of this moment so this is a photo it's a
photo by learning our thoughts also
taken today and this again was played
you can see on screen on f8 the queen is
restless you know she's leaning to the
left I have no idea why the Queen is
leaning to the left probably maybe Anand
slam that's too hard so you know it
didn't settle or maybe we should knocked
it over you know very interesting but
you can see there's a lot a lot of
energy to this photo so yeah also you
know I will put all of the Leonard's
links in social media in the description
below so feel free to follow him as well
he also has amazing photos from it from
a lot of chess events so be sure to
check it out so yeah that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it and let's check
out the standings after nine rounds of
blitz on day one
so sorry about that so these are the
standings Wesley so is still in the lead
but these are the combined scores from
the rapid em blades so with combined
scores Wesley so still leading in the
grand chest were followed by 11 Iranian
Sergei kurakin Maxine Bashir al agraja
Cara Nakamura Alexander district manager
of Vishwanathan Anand
Fabiana Caruana and onigiri so Kara
wanna definitely not having the greatest
day in rappin but also let's check out
these are the standings if you consider
only the Blitz games that were played so
without without adding the points from
the rapid so considering only today's
blitz and nine games of blitz it's
actually surgery Kerrigan in the lead
with four points zero losses and five
draws followed by 11 Aragon and Hikaru
Nakamura then Greece took them on and
then Maxine Marshall DeGraw Wesley so
onigiri shocker mommy DRF and Fabiano
Caruana with zero wins four losses and
five draws are terrible they you know
for the World Chess Championship
challenger in rapid and blitz and he's
definitely gonna have to improve
something or if he plans to win he
better beat Magnus II while he's still
in classical time format so yeah that's
the game and the coverage so far I do
hope you're enjoying everything
including the photos I would like to
thank you lien show and for a
contribution to my channel you and said
that I have to use it to enjoy some nice
craft beer at my festival so that is
exactly what I am going to do after I
upload this video so yeah as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
think all for watching and I will see
you soon tomorrow probably as tomorrow
is also my birthday
so we'll see I will cover definitely a
couple of games from the lumen
tournament but you know we'll see how
things go
so yeah thing go and I'll see you soon